bien ahora voy a hacer el análisis de
esta configuración de amplificador
operacional otra vez y la haré
utilizando el concepto de tierra
virtual
y el concepto de tierra virtual de hecho
hace que sea muy rápido analizar un
circuito como éste repasemos el concepto
de tierra virtual
y que si este voltaje de aquí si el
voltaje de salida está en un rango
razonable entre las fuentes de
alimentación del amplificador y recuerda
las fuentes de alimentación no se
muestran aquí pero están conectadas al
hub este es un número entre 0 y más
menos 10 volts algo así y la ganancia de
este amplificador es muy grande es
simplemente gigantesca está alrededor de
los cientos de miles o millones así que
mientras haya un valor de voltaje normal
aquí entonces el voltaje aquí será muy
cercano a cero está en el orden de micro
volts y el concepto de tierra virtual
dice que si este nodo de aquí está a
cero volts el cual dibujamos conectado a
tierra así que está a cero volts eso
significa que esta terminal impresora
estará también a cero volts muy cercana
a cero volts y eso hace de esto
virtualmente
o una tierra virtual
otra manera de escribir esto es decir
que f más es aproximadamente igual a b -
el profesor que me enseñó esto tenía un
pequeño símbolo para la tierra virtual
lo que hacía era dibujarlo de esta
manera así que puedes dibujarlo
entusiama un simple símbolo ayudará a
recordarte que esos dos nodos están en
el mismo voltaje bien hagamos el
análisis otra vez teníamos r1 y esta era
r 2 y tenemos una corriente fluyendo
aquí la llamaré y y podemos escribir una
expresión para y el voltaje en este lado
el voltaje en este lado de la
resistencia es el voltaje de entrada
y el voltaje en este lado de la
resistencia es de 0 volts es de 0 volts
porque tenemos una tierra virtual aquí
así que sabemos el voltaje en ambos
extremos puedo decir que iu es igual a
la diferencia de voltaje el voltaje de
entrada
- 0 nos queda solo el voltaje de entrada
dividido entre r
así que tenemos una expresión para y
como recuerdas otra cosa que sabemos de
los amplificadores operacionales es que
la corriente de aquí
pero no hay corriente atravesando la
entrada de un amplificador operacional
ideal en un amplificador real habrá una
corriente muy pequeña ahí para nuestros
fines
podríamos ahora considerar como si no
hubiera corriente aquí eso qué significa
significa que y fluye a través de r2
escribamos una expresión para ir
atravesando r2
necesitamos saber el voltaje en cada
extremo de r2 en este lado es igual al
voltaje de salida
este lado es igual al voltaje de salida
y en este lado nuevamente usaremos el 0
así que la corriente a través de r2 es
igual a
pongamos el signo correcto
la corriente va en esta dirección así
que este es relativamente el signo
positivo y este es el negativo así que y
es 0 - el voltaje de salida
/ / r 2
bien hagamos a estas dos corrientes
iguales la una a la otra eso significa
que el voltaje de entrada
sobre r 1 es igual a menos el voltaje de
salida
sobre rectos y lo que queremos es una
expresión que nos diga lo que es el
voltaje de salida en términos del
voltaje de entrada así que el voltaje de
salida
es igual al voltaje de entrada
por y veamos r2 va arriba
r uno va abajo
y hay un signo negativo
y lo logramos esa es la expresión del
voltaje de salida en términos del
voltaje de entrada para la configuración
de amplificador inversor ahora
utilizando el concepto de tierra virtual
el análisis se volvió muy sencillo
básicamente tomo uno dos tres pasos
llegar a la respuesta si comparamos eso
con el desarrollo algebraico que hicimos
en el vídeo anterior cuando partimos de
los primeros principios ese es un
ejemplo donde se aplicó el concepto de
tierra virtual para analizar un circuito
con amplificadores operacionales haré
uno más muy rápido
esta es una configuración diferente con
amplificadores operacionales no hemos
visto esta antes lo primero que hay que
notar es que ahora el signo positivo
está arriba siempre echa un vistazo a tu
amplificador para ver qué terminal está
arriba y aquí está el voltaje de entrada
como siempre y acá está el voltaje de
salida
y nuevamente lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar el voltaje de salida en
términos del voltaje de entrada este
circuito no tiene resistencias en él y
está bien descubriremos lo que está
pasando aquí apliquemos el concepto de
tierra virtual dibujaré mi pequeño
símbolo de tierra virtual aquí
de esta manera eso me recuerda que estas
dos terminales tienen el mismo voltaje
si lo hacemos de la manera adecuada
encontremos el valor del voltaje de
salida el voltaje de salida es igual a
esta terminal de aquí y esta es
prácticamente igual que ésta y cuál es
esta esta es el voltaje de entrada
así que bum
ya acabamos en un solo paso esa es la
respuesta a esta configuración se le
conoce como
cx pero
paul
también es conocido como
amplificador
ganancia
ganancia unitaria
calificador
y esto es sólo una manera larga de decir
que la ganancia es uno ese es un ejemplo
de un seguidor de voltaje y utilizamos
el concepto de tierra virtual para
analizarlo casi instantáneamente